AMAZING.
GOD BLESS THE FAMILY TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR SAYING THOSE
WORDS, SEAN AND I WILL TAKE OVER
WHERE YOU LEFT OFF.
I AM LAURA INGRAHAM OF THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
A BUSY WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
WE'LL START WITH THIS.
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT ANGLE.
HERE IS MY MESSAGE.
IF YOU READ ONE ARTICLE THIS
WEEK ABOUT OUR POLITICAL
PARTIES, IT SHOULD BE THIS PIECE
JUST PUBLISHED BY AXIOS TITLED
"THE GREAT REALIGNMENT."
THE GIST IS THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
BECOMING MORE POPULIST WHILE
DEMOCRATS ARE BECOMING MORE
ELITIST.
IF THESE TRENDS CONTINUE, THE
PARTY OF BIDEN AND PELOSI IS
DESTINED FOR HISTORICAL LOSSES
IN THE NEXT ELECTION CYCLE.
NOT JUST IN TRADITIONALLY RED
STATES, BY THE WAY.
SHIFTS IN THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
THE TWO PARTY SUPPORTERS ARE
ARGUABLY THE BIGGEST POLITICAL
STORY OF OUR TIME.
THE BIG PICTURE, REPUBLICANS ARE
BECOMING MORE WORKING-CLASS AND
A LITTLE MORE MULTIRACIAL.
DEMOCRATS ARE BECOMING MORE
ELITE AND A LITTLE MORE WHITE.
HUH.
THIS MOVEMENT OF MINORITIES
TOWARD THE G.O.P. BEGAN IN
EARNEST UNDER DONALD TRUMP.
HE GREW REPUBLICAN SUPPORT AMONG
BLACK AND HISPANIC VOTERS IN
2016 AND BUILT ON THOSE GAINS IN
2020.
IN FACT, HE CLOSE THE GAP AMONG
HISPANIC VOTERS BY 17 POINTS,
ACCORDING TO PEW ANALYSIS.
SEEMED TO LIKE TRUMP'S NO
NONSENSE APPROACH AND POST
MOBILE IS IN HIS.
HIS TONE AND LANGUAGE TOWARD
ILLEGALS AND SUPPORT FOR
BUILDING THE BORDER WALL DIDN'T
SEEM TO BOTHER THEM MUCH.
>> I AM A FORMER CHIEF OF POLICE
IN A BORDER TOWN.
I'M HISPANIC.
PROUD TO BE HISPANIC.
I AM 100% BEHIND DONALD TRUMP.
>> I AM AN AMERICAN GRADUATE
STUDENT HERE AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF TEXAS.
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY BELIEVE THAT
MR. DONALD J. TRUMP WILL MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
>> I WAS BORN IN TIJUANA,
MEXICO.
I AM VOTING FOR DONALD TRUMP TO
BE THE NEXT PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: FOR THEIR PART,
DEMOCRATS INCORRECTLY ASSUME
THAT THE MORE THEIR PARTY MOVES
TOWARDS BIG GOVERNMENT
SOCIALISM, THE MORE MINORITIES
IT ATTRACTS.
TALK ABOUT A HUGE
MISCALCULATION.
MORE FROM THIS AXIOS ANALYSIS.
THE DATA SHOWS DEMOCRATS ARE
STATISTICALLY TIED WITH
REPUBLICANS AMONG HISPANICS ON
THE GENERIC CONGRESSIONAL
BALLOT, ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SIENA
COLLEGE POLL OUT THIS WEEK.
DEMOCRATS HELD THE 47-POINT EDGE
WITH HISPANICS DURING THE 2018
MIDTERM.
THAT IS A STAGGERING COLLAPSE.
WE ALREADY KNOW BIDEN'S APPROVAL
WITH HISPANICS TODAY IS IN THE
TOILET.
ONLY 32% NOW APPROVE OF HIS JOB
PERFORMANCE ACCORDING TO A
RECENT "NEW YORK TIMES" SIENA
COLLEGE POLL.
SO HOW DOES THIS ALL TRANSLATE
IN THE NOVEMBER MIDTERMS?
DEMOCRATS HOPE FOR RETAINING
POWER RESTS ON NONWHITE VOTERS
REMAINING A RELIABLE PART OF THE
PARTIES COALITION.
DEMOCRATS' THEORY OF THE CASE
COLLAPSES IF REPUBLICANS MAKE
EVEN INCREMENTAL GAINS WITH
THOSE VOTERS, EVEN SMALL INROADS
WITH HISPANIC VOTERS COULD TIP A
NUMBER OF DEMOCRATIC HELD SWING
SEEDS TO THE G.O.P.
OF COURSE, FOR YEARS THE
REPUBLICAN ELITES DEVOTED TO THE
BUSH CHENEY WORLDVIEW, THEY
THOUGHT THEY COULD JUST
STEAMROLL THEIR OPPOSITION
WITHIN THE G.O.P. REGARDLESS OF
HOW BAD THINGS GOT.
THEIR ANSWER TO LOSING IN 2008
AND THEN AGAIN IN 2012 WAS JUST
MORE OF THE SAME.
>> FOR THE LAST 15 MONTHS, I
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE NEED TO
GET IMMIGRATION REFORM DONE.
>> I HAVE MADE IT ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR THAT I BELIEVE WE NEED
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
>> WE ARE A NATION OF
IMMIGRANTS.
THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO ABANDON
SOMETHING THAT MAKES US SPECIAL
AND UNIQUE.
>> Laura: THEY THOUGHT THEY
WOULD NOMINATE JEB IN 2016 WHO
WOULD BEAT HILLARY AND THEN ALL
WOULD BE WELL.
IT WOULD RETURN TO THE OLD DAYS.
SO THEY WERE STUNNED WHEN THE
VOTERS REJECTED ANOTHER BUSH IN
2016.
MORE IMMIGRATION, ENDLESS WARS,
MORE BAD TRADE DEALS.
NOT POPULAR.
TELLING THEM MIDDLE-CLASS
WORKERS AND FAMILIES WERE FED UP
BUT THE REPUBLICAN ELITES FREE
-- REFUSED TO LISTEN.
IT ACTS ES WE POPULISTS WERE
CORRECT AND THE G.O.P.
ESTABLISHMENT, THEY WERE WRONG.
WE GREW THE PARTY.
WE MADE IT A BIG TENT.
THEY SHRUNK IT.
BECAUSE WE HAVE MADE SO MUCH
PROGRESS SINCE I'VE BEEN G.O.P.,
WE ARE SEEING A WHOLE NEW
GENERATION OF EXCITING NEW
CANDIDATES ACROSS AMERICA, LIKE
MYRA FLOREZ AND J.D. VANCE.
>> GAS, FOOD, MEDICATION.
WE CANNOT ACCEPT THAT.
>> I AM SICK AND SOME ON THE
LEFT DESTROYING THE COUNTRY.
AND SICK OF THOSE WHO REFUSED TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST IT.
>> Laura: THE G.O.P. OLD GUARD
CLAIMING SO DESPERATELY THEY
WANTED TO BRING MINORITIES INTO
POLITICS ARE SUDDENLY FLUMMOXED.
THESE WEREN'T THE TYPE OF
CANDIDATES THEY WERE HOPING FOR.
MANY OF THE CANDIDATES THAT ARE
RISING NOW, THEY GOT INTO
POLITICS BECAUSE OF TRUMP.
BY CONTRAST, YOU HAVE TO
CONSIDER THE PROBLEMS ON THE
LEFT.
THE SQUAD AND THEIR SUPPORTERS
COMPLAIN THEY WERE GOING TO
FIGHT FOR THE WORKING PEOPLE.
THEY WERE GOING TO STAND UP TO
BUSINESS AND OPPOSE FOOLISH WARS
BUT THEY DIDN'T KEEP THOSE
PROMISES, DID THEY?
INSTEAD OF WORKING WITH US TO
BUILD A SOCIETY THAT WOULD BE
FAIRER AND MORE PROSPEROUS FOR
THE AVERAGE PERSON, THE AMERICAN
LEFT HAS ALLIED THEMSELVES WITH
THE BIDENS, THE CHENEYS, AND THE
BUSHES ON THE REST OF THE GLOBAL
ESTABLISHMENT THAT CREATED SO
MANY OF THE DISASTERS WE ARE
DEALING WITH NOW.
WORKING-CLASS PEOPLE KNOW THE
LEFT ISN'T THE ANSWER ANYMORE.
ONLY THE POPULISTS ARE BUILDING
A MOVEMENT, THAT BIG TENT, THAT
WILL ACTUALLY STAND UP FOR THE
LITTLE GUY.
SO WHILE THE LEFT TALKS ABOUT
RESISTING THE PLUTOCRATS, THEY
ARE ACTUALLY DOING NOTHING.
WE ARE ACTUALLY DOING THE HEAVY
LIFTING.
JUST ASK DISNEY OR THE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE OR LIZ CHENEY FOR
THAT MATTER.
WE ARE NOT JUST RESISTING.
WE ARE WINNING.
WHAT IS THE LAST TIME AOC OR
ILHAN OMAR OR AYANNA PRESSLEY
ACCOMPLISHED ANYTHING FOR THE
WORKING CLASS?
THE FACTS OF THE LAST FEW YEARS
WE'VE NO DOUBT THAT OUR POLICIES
WORK FOR THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
WHILE THE ESTABLISHMENT POLICIES
DON'T.
LOOK AT HOW WELL WE WERE DOING
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO UNDER
TRUMP.
LOOK AT HOW POORLY WE ARE DOING
NOW.
SO THIS STRUGGLE BETWEEN OUR
POPULIST MOVEMENT ON ONE SIDE
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT ALONG WITH
ITS LEFTIST ALLIES ON THE OTHER,
IT'S THE GREAT POLITICAL DEBATE
OF OUR TIME.
IF THE ESTABLISHMENT WINS, THE
FUTURE OF AMERICA WILL BE BLEAK.
MORE INFLATION, MORE RECESSION,
MORE WARS, MORE CRIME, MORE
POVERTY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE IN MIND
FOR US.
THAT'S WHAT THEIR POLICIES ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S WHAT
THEIR POLICIES ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO.
IT ALWAYS WORKS OUT THAT WAY.
BUT IF WE WIN, THE NEXT 20 YEARS
CAN BE A NEW GOLDEN AGE WITH
PEACE AND PROSPERITY BROADLY
ENJOYED ACROSS DEMOGRAPHIC
LINES.
WE CAN END THESE STUPID WARS.
WE CAN PUT AMERICANS BACK TO
WORK.
WE CAN HAVE MORE PRODUCTIVITY
AND HIGHER WAGES.
STREETS, YEAH, THEY'LL BE SAFE
TO WALK IN AND SCHOOLS THAT
ACTUALLY TEACH USEFUL SKILLS.
WE CAN HAVE A GOVERNMENT THAT
PROMOTES AMERICA INSTEAD OF
ALWAYS TEARING IT DOWN.
AND THE MEDIA, THEY KNOW WE ARE
WINNING.
THAT'S WHY AXIOS WROTE THIS
PIECE.
THAT'S WHY THE MEDIA ARE
SUDDENLY TRYING TO GET RID OF
BIDEN.
THAT'S WHY THEY REMAIN OBSESSED
WITH TRUMP, WHY THEY KEEP TRYING
TO SMEAR DeSANTIS AND OTHER
POPULIST REPUBLICANS.
THE PRESS COULDN'T STOP REAGAN
IN 1980.
THEY COULDN'T STOP TRUMP IN
2016, AND THEY NEEDED A PANDEMIC
AND PERPETUAL WITCH HUNT TO STOP
HIM IN 2020.
I FULLY EXPECT THE PLUTOCRAT
CLASS TO WORK OVERTIME TO TRY TO
TURN THINGS AROUND FOR
GLOBALISM.
GEORGE SOROS, GATES, ZUCKERBERG,
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO GIVE UP
BECAUSE BIDEN IS FLOUNDERING.
THEY'RE GOING TO DOUBLE DOWN TO
PROTECT A SYSTEM THAT ENRICHES
THEM.
THEY DON'T CARE IF YOU SUFFER.
IT'S IRRELEVANT TO THEM.
THEY HAVE PROFITED OFF AMERICA'S
DECLINE IN CHINA'S RISE.
NOW IT'S TIME TO BEAT THEM AND
BEAT THEM BADLY, TO TAKE AWAY
THEIR POWER AND RETURN IT TO THE
PEOPLE WHERE IT RIGHTLY BELONGS.
SO WE MUST DEFEAT THEM ONE BY
ONE IN THE SENATE, THE HOUSE,
EVERY GOVERNOR'S RACE, THE STATE
HOUSES AND EVEN THE SCHOOL
BOARDS.
NO STATE SHOULD BE LEFT BEHIND.
WE CAN'T GIVE UP ON OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS TRAPPED IN PLACES LIKE
CHICAGO OR BALTIMORE,
SAN FRANCISCO.
A POLITICAL REALIGNMENT IS
UNDERWAY AND THE PATIENTS AND
OPTIMISM, WE ARE GOING TO KEEP
BUILDING THIS FREEDOM MOVEMENT
AND WHEN W